how's it going bros my beautify and
today I'm here with these two lovely
ladies stuff mr. Pierce funny and my mom
yeah yeah I'm the ghost of Maya I asked
you both to ask you some questions
around the since you're here it's my
birthday
we'll see what you asked okay my
questions about goodbye I get my ego
from that's you right question what is
it like being related to a beard oh the
kind of weirdos talk about you okay okay
no no oh
don't butter me up here most
embarrassing thing Felix did as a child
why should we start
oh I wasn't embarrassing no actually
when I was kind of a skeptic thank you
there you go I've got it on camera
describe one word for me fabulous ah I
would say fabulous easy obviously runs
in the family
great way vices do you ever watch my
videos yes we want to know I watch them
okay right listen ladies I think the
nice we did was actually was mash this
video oh I like to wash it
and my ass is in videos and asking about
me I get it
all right when did you find out that
Felix was a duck today you learned
something you area didn't I easy calm I
can I stepped up the dummy insulted your
mouth was none of that
oh you want that small that's my thanks
ah okay this is for you mom okay what
did you eat to have a fabulous like what
Oh what should i do diet actually get
the real high yeah
your sister is hot send us patient no
next one wall command command yeah Wow
no don't see anything
yes please right yeah because you like
them why I'm coloring because he would
like to dress up as a god I don't
remember this yes but we do we applied
yes you went into the date excellent
better as it as a car and all the
teacher thought that I was a weird
person I think all the teachers thought
it was fabulous were you see really
hoping for me to turn gay or something
yes I had to make that now you were
hoping for easier I was well I kinda got
half of it manova presence a try why
hasn't your son bought you
are you nah we just had an umbrella on
it from your sweetie okay should Felix
quit YouTube and get a real job no but
you should move back to Sweden yeah yeah
are you part of live with me naughty
excuse me
we must supposed to discuss this what
party my mom pretends to be happy never
your feelings for the girl what would
you name her horse Felice yeah what was
Felix first forward that was bad
good eye it wasn't really a word but she
said God because he was such a happy
child other children means when they
wake up they they cry but he just
laughed it was happy he said good and he
said girl and what they love me I think
it's me preparing for that one
ah we can talk about the girls I fell in
love with you yes and you didn't want to
go so we thought you were gay
yeah that's what we were absolutely
ready girls
there were like knocking on the door she
came to get our house and knocked on our
door and I said oh sorry
I want my video game priorities so we
weren't actually sure that's that's how
you for video games over email so that
your game okay - thank you I mean I
thank you for the vine oh it was oh good
all right pres if you enjoyed this video
please go ahead and leave a like and
that's all for me for now
invisible brofist